this episode is sponsored by wandream a
subscription service where you can find
the answers to everything you've ever
wondered about and some things you've
never imagined you would wonder about
head to onedrive.com microcosmos for a
free trial
[Music]
if the micro microcosmos is like many
tiny oceans all around us filled with
its own fantastic creatures you might
imagine this paramecium as a barge
traveling through those waters
all along its edges are many cilia at
work
beating and steering it along the
striations that stretch down its body
are on full display long and smooth
until the paramecium brushes up against
its neighbors and those lines compress
against each other turning the barge
into maybe more of a blimp
whatever large mode of transportation
you choose to compare it to though the
paramecium is slow and steady
except that actually
it isn't
the slowness
the steadiness
we did that
all thanks to the wonder of slow motion
unless we note otherwise all of the
footage that you are going to be seeing
in this video today has been slowed down
james our master of microscopes filmed
these videos with a high speed camera we
don't have one of those really fancy
cameras that can record tens of
thousands of frames per second but it
does record at 240 frames per second
which lets us show you footage that is
eight times slower than what we would
normally show on this channel and the
results we think are beautiful and kind
of soothing and i've been really looking
forward to sharing them with you
[Music]
don't get us wrong the microcosmos at
full speed is beautiful and soothing as
well but like with this ciliate here
sometimes the spinning and whirling
happens so quickly that it's difficult
to make out the details we keep just
getting a glance of it before it moves
out of frame or twists out of focus and
describing the movements it makes seems
to take more time than the movement
itself actually does
but while we cannot command the ciliate
into the right position we can slow it
down after the fact and that
is amazing
i mean
imagine the work that early
microscopists had to do centuries before
video even existed to illustrate with
words and withdrawings what they saw to
evoke movements in the microcosmos for
others who would never be able to see
those exact movements
and not only can we share those moments
with tens or hundreds of thousands of
people we can slow them down to see new
details in them like the large vacuole
opening and closing at one end of this
ciliate
[Music]
slowing down the micro cosmos does not
necessarily mean everything travels at
the same slow speed though
the giant blepharisma and spirostomum
here for example may be idly passing
through but they are surrounded on all
sides by the still frantic rotations and
vibrations of corkscrew-shaped bacteria
and at the other end we have the spiky
ciliate actinibolina almost static
except for its toxic tentacles waving
like blue blades of grass in a
microscopic breeze
[Music]
[Music]
the movements are subtle and they can
lull you into a sense that nothing is
really happening but this is the
microcosmos there is
always something happening it just takes
some patience and attention to notice
[Music]
so
over time the act and abelina's
tentacles have stretched out making the
organism look like a faceless puffer
fish like we said we're fortunate to
have the technology to see these acts
unfold but this is not the only way to
stretch time in the microcosmos
[Music]
in the early 20th century for example
scientists wanted to be able to see the
movement of cilia more clearly after all
cilia is a remarkable feat of
coordination and movement driven not by
limbs but by hair-like organelles
however one cannot simply ask a ciliate
to slow down a bit so that there's time
to take notes and ask questions it will
move at its own speed on its own time
so scientists turned to reagents to do
what's called fixation
an act that's like freezing the cells in
a moment of time
with its last moments on display like a
memory stuck on repeat until it slowly
degrades away
now we're being a bit melodramatic about
the effects of fixation because we can
be for our purposes video gives us all
we need to look at microbes without
knowingly putting them at risk we can
see this stenter's cilia beating
creating a curled path through its body
even the texture of the cilia seems
almost tangible like this like you could
imagine
running your hands across this microbe
and feeling the silky fringe
brushing your fingertips
and for us with what we hope to see of
the macrocosmos that is enough
but fixation is a useful technique in
biology that is still used today and for
the scientists studying silly emotion
fixation allowed them to see cilia more
clearly to make out the structures and
coordination at work
and you can see that movement here on
this didinium one small band wrapped
around the middle and a larger band
hanging like a giant mustache
as the camera shifts focus the hair
along the organism's body becomes less
visible and instead the only visible
cilia are the ones flapping on the side
of the organism
those coordinated movements we see the
ones that scientists used chemical
reagents and electron microscopy to
describe is called the metacronal wave
it is each cilia beating just slightly
behind one neighbor and a head of the
next like a crowd doing the wave in a
stadium as each wave travels through
individuals and then the crowd the
organism moves
the micro cosmos travels at many speeds
we see it every week with each new video
on this channel and the microbes we
watch together
and it is to us at least nice to know
that however much we can slow down
together to enjoy this it is always
possible to go just a bit slower
but when we look deeper however we do it
somehow there's always something new to
find
but also
always another breath we can take just
to think
to imagine
and to enjoy
[Music]
so thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you also to
wandrium for sponsoring this episode one
dream is where you can find the answer
to everything you've ever wondered about
and some things you've never imagined
you would wonder about their carefully
curated collection of short and long
form videos tutorials how to's
travelogues documentaries and more is
academically comprehensive thoroughly
researched relentlessly entertaining and
presented by engaging experts in a
nutshell
one dream is the place for minds that
wonder there you can find incredible
courses like mysteries of the
microscopic world where they dive into
the world of microbes and discuss how
they function how we discovered them how
they harm and help us and how we
continue to compete coexist and
co-evolve with them if you're looking to
be inspired one dream might be right for
you and they're giving journey to the
microcosmos viewers a free trial so head
on over to onedream.com microcosmos to
subscribe hey look there's a bunch of
names on your screen right now these
people are folks who i don't know if
they did it slowly or quickly maybe they
watched like a year of episodes before
they decided or maybe the moment they
saw it they went to patreon.com journey
to micro and they became
our patreon patrons and we appreciate it
so so much you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to become one
of them if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss you
can check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you